♪ ♪ ♪
- Trois-Rivières, c'est l'une
des circonscriptions au Québec
qui est vraiment dans la mire
des conservateurs et c'est peut-
être là où ils avaient le plus
d'espoir de faire des gains,
en 2021. Mais la défaite a été
crève-coeur : ils ont perdu par
moins de 100 voix.
♪ ♪ ♪
(sonnette)
- Bonjour, ça va bien, Laurence?
- Comment ça va, M. Lévesque?
- Bienvenue à Trois-Rivières.
- Merci.
- La plus belle ville du Canada!
- C'est Yves Lévesque, l'ancien
maire, qui se présentait pour le
parti. Il raconte à quel point
il a été surpris des résultats
de la dernière campagne.
YVES LÉVESQUE, ex-candidat,
PCC, Trois-Rivières, Qc
- M. Legault, le premier
ministre, a recommandé au niveau
fédéral le Parti conservateur.
Malgré ce fait-là, on n'a gagné
aucun siège!
- Selon lui, les tergiversations
du chef Erin O'Toole et
son manque de clarté sur
plusieur o o o o ont empêché
les conservateurs d'aller
chercher des sièges additionnels
au Québec.
- On disait toujours :
n n n n n plan, j'ai un plan,
j'ai un plan. T'sais, un moment
donné, oui, mais c'est quoi,
ton plan? Il faut pas que
ça soit compliqué non plus.Même.
- Il était épais.
Il était épais.
- Il y en avait trop, t'sais,
il y en avait trop! Même moi,
j'en perdais mon latin.
- Yves Lévesque croit que
les électeurs québécois
ne sont pas très dogmatiques et
peuvent appuyer toutes sortes de
leaders, pourvu qu'il exprime
clairement ce qu'il pense.
Il cite en exemple Pierre
Poilièvre, le seul candidat
déclaré jusqu'à maintenant.
- Si vous l'écoutez, c'est
quelqu'un qui défend ses idées
d'aplomb.
- Après notre discussion,
il rend visite à deux
admirateurs de longue date.
FRANCINE LAPOINTE
- Ben là, vous avez manqué
le bout où on vous a encensé!
- Francine et Serge ont déjà
voté pour plusieurs partis
fédéraux, comme le Bloc et
le NPD, mais ils ont choisi
d'appuyer les conservateurs
aux deux dernières élections
parce qu'ils adorent
leur candidat local.
- M. Trudeau, c'est comme
s'il avait une machine à argent
dans sa chambre.
- Bien oui!
- Inévitablement, le choix
du prochain chef conservateur
se glisse dans la conversation.
- Va voir le Facebook de
Pierre Poilièvre.
- Francine et Serge
le connaissent peu.
Celui qu'ils connaissent,
c'est l'ex-premier ministre
québécois Jean Charest,
qui songe sérieusement à
se lancer dans la course.
- Il y a tellement de choses
dans son garde-robe.
Dans un débat, ils vont
revenir sur la corruption,
la corruption, la corruption.
- Francine aussi a des doutes.
- Le reste du Canada,
ils nous aiment pas beaucoup,
le Québec. J'ai de la difficulté
à croire que le reste du Canada
va voter pour un chef qui vient
du Québec.
- Son mari d'ailleurs ne sait
pas si la grande famille
conservatrice va parvenir à
rester unie bien longtemps.
SERGE DUBÉ
- Aujourd'hui, la minute où
on se parle, le parti est
en péril. Pour l'instant, avec
ce qu'on entend et qu'on voit,
il n'y a pas d'unité.
♪ ♪ ♪
- On est en route en ce moment
vers Québec, qui est une région
où les conservateurs détiennent
cinq sièges, la moitié de
leurs circonscriptions dans
la province. Et pour eux,
c'est vraiment considéré
comme un terreau fertile.
♪ ♪ ♪
Dans ce petit restaurant
au nord de Charlesbourg,
ces trois militants croient
qu'il y a moyen de rassembler
les conservateurs au pays,
à condition de mettre la saine
gestion des finances publiques
à l'avant-plan.
NANCY JOANNETTE, bénévole, PCC,
Charlesbourg-Hte-St-Charles, Qc
- L'économie, avec la pandémie,
ça n'a pas été facile pour
personne. Ça fait qu'il faut
remettre ça en jeu.
- Et surtout, à condition de
ne pas s'embourber dans
les enjeux de droite sociale,
comme l'avortement.
THOMAS VERRET, militant, PCC
Charlesbourg-Hte-St-Charles, Qc
- Dans les chaumières,
les gens parlent pas de ça, là!
Ça fait consensus.
- Clairement, c'est la recette
que précisent bien des députés
conservateurs de la région.
PIERRE PAUL-HUS, député, PCC,
Charlesbourg-Hte-St-Charles, Qc
- Moi, ce que je dis à
mes collègues, quand je parle à
mes collègues de l'Ouest ou
d'ailleurs, c'est qu'au Québec,
on aime ça quand c'est modéré.
- Dans la région, il y a cinq
députés pour la ville de Québec.
- Mais un autre membre du caucus
québécois craint que la base
dans l'Ouest ne suive pas.
JOËL GODIN, député, PCC,
Portneuf-Jacques-Cartier, Qc
- Est-ce qu'eux sont
plus réceptifs à être
progressistes-conservateurs?
J'en doute, honnêtement.
- Il redoute une scission
dans le parti et n'est pas
certain de rester si le prochain
chef n'est pas un progressiste-
conservateur. Et ça inclut
Pierre Poilièvre, qu'il trouve
parfois trop versé vers
la droite populiste, avec
son appui aux camionneurs.
- Si M. Poilièvre devient
le chef du Parti conservateur
du Canada, je vais amorcer
ma réflexion.
- Pour d'autres, le choix du
leader ne sera pas déterminant.
CLAUDETTE LAFOREST, bénévole PCC
Charlesbourg-Hte-St-Charles, Qc
- Moi, peu importe qui
va rentrer, je vais toujours
les appuyer. Je suis toujours
conservateur!
(rires)
- Parfois l'allégeance est plus
forte que les différences.
♪ ♪